have you ever wondered where is the
cheapest area to buy a house in the uk
right now in 2022 well i'm going to hit
you with the cheapest area in fact i've
got the 10 cheapest areas in the entire
country and i'm going to give you them
right now i've done a lot of research
into this video so that you don't have
to so if you enjoy my channel do me a
favor hit the like button here we go i'm
going to start with the 10th the 10th
cheapest area in the country right now
to buy is a place called kiely keeley is
bd21 keely the average house you can buy
in keely is 91
833 grand that's crazy buying a house
for less than a hundred thousand pounds
let me tell you something really
interesting about keeley as well before
i move on to point number nine keely
i've got so many students that are
crushing kakini right now jl jl spooner
who was one of my first ever students
she's buying houses in chile really
cheap and she's buying them on lease
option agreements so that means that
she's saying okay the house is worth 91
grand i'll buy it
for a hundred grand i'll pay you 10 000
pounds over the odds but i'll pay you in
seven years so she's securing all these
properties in keely but then she's
renting them out on a room by room basis
evans is doing the same my boy evans
willie just secured i think he's a seven
eight bed
hmo with and he's just got plenty
permission to put an apartment below in
the basement so it's a very very cheap
area where you can make lots of money
that's number ten number nine even
cheaper than keeley you want to know
where it's cheaper than keeley i'ma hit
you with it liverpool
l20 maybe you think liverpool's the
cheapest area in the uk it's not it's
the ninth cheapest
the average price in l20 liverpool is 91
793 pounds and liverpool is one of those
areas that i believe i've been saying
this for the last couple years
is up and coming the city of liverpool
is banging serviced accommodation works
really well there as well people are
traveling they're going to watch the
matches do shopping you know crept crept
and conan i helped prep buy a house in
liverpool he bought a house for 43 000
pounds
but it was run down he rents that out as
a hmo so there's demand for hmos service
accommodation l20 average price 91
793
number eight what's up next i haven't
got too much familiarity with this place
okay this is lancashire bb11
also 91 and 516 so slightly cheaper than
l20 liverpool and um i've done a bit of
research on lancashire specifically this
part of lancashire in bb11 where you can
buy houses on average for 91 516 pounds
and the average rent
is 455 pounds so the thing is with that
this is why i've never been there it's
bb11 although you can buy a house for
cheap 91 516 pounds the rent is also
really cheap like 555 pounds so the
return on investment is not going to be
amazing i'm sure it's better than lots
of places but that's lancashire anyway
up number seven the seventh most
cheapest part of the country where do
you think it is stanley
stanley is dh9
and you could buy a house for 91 391
pounds the rent is higher than bb11 so
you're buying it a bit cheaper and
you're renting it higher with the rent
that 492.
next up five we're almost halfway there
i hope you enjoyed the video if you are
hit like i spend so much time
researching this stuff most of these
areas i've bought houses myself as well
so i'm not just giving you the the
figures i'm also giving you the stories
and the back stories about the areas uh
next is peter lee peter lee sr8
i recently bought a house in peterlee
okay the average house
in sr8 peterley the average house is 85
grand
can you believe that the average house
is 85 000 to be specific 85 274 that's
like
how much houses were worth
15 20 years ago crazy i recently bought
a house in peterlee or just next to it
for 36 000 pounds and the rent on that
is about 500 pounds a month so again the
returns i wrote a whole book called buy
low rent high the returns are staggering
in peterlee
number five
sheldon
don't know much about sheldon but when i
did a little bit of google research
there was a murder there
last week
so
don't think just because an area is
really cheap that you should definitely
rush to go buy a house there because if
there's like murders happening
you might get bad tenants it's not just
about the return on investment it's also
about the quality of the tenants so
sheldon the average house in sheldon dl4
which is part of county durham is just
73
637 pounds so you buy an average house
in the area for 73 grand it's gonna get
even cheaper in a minute this is going
to blow your brains next up grimsby
number four in fourth place dn31 dn31
the average house what are you what are
you guessing guys i'm saying i'm telling
you right here
71
and 105 pounds
intro let me tell you something
interesting about groomsmen because i've
invested in grimsby previously i've also
packaged and sold a lot of hmos in
grimsby grimsby
is completely unregulated as far as hmos
go so you can buy a house in grimsby
on average you're going to pay 71 grand
which means you're gonna put down a
deposit
25 which is what about 20 grand so if
you've got 20 grand
you can buy a house right now in grimsby
grimsby is unregulated as far as hmos
are concerned there's no article 4 so
you can buy a house and you can rent it
out on a room by room basis now that is
what i was doing back in 2016 and um we
had quite a few of my students that were
like absolutely went crazy on grimsby
because it was so cheap at the time i
think the average house was like 60
grand it's gone up a little bit and they
were buying houses and grims be like
bang bang bang bang renting them out
room by room and because grimby is a
small place what happened was it it got
a little bit over saturated so grimsby
suddenly became like hmo city and there
was just
rooms there was so much supply of rooms
that suddenly the rooms became hard to
rent out because there wasn't actually
that many people looking to rent rooms
however i feel like the tables have
turned now because it got oversaturated
people stopped doing hmos and grimsby
now actually i think it's a pretty
viable business model so you can buy an
average house in dm33 grimsby for 71
grand and you can legally rent it out
room by room without a license if
there's less than five people without
planning permission no article four
that's crazy next up number three number
three cheapest in the country is
sunderland sunderland is so cheap
my friends just bought he was going to
buy a house in sunderland but instead he
bought a whole apartment block
okay he bought a whole apartment block
28 apartments the average house in
sunderland is just 65 this is sr1 of
sunderland
hundred and 65
eight pounds
so you can literally buy a buy a house
for 65 grand and again you can rent it
out room by room um
my friend pete
found this apartment block because it
was so massive
the guy that was selling it wanted 650
grand but that's for 28 apartments
and pete didn't have the money so pete
said to him same story i'll give you 650
grand
but i'll give it you in seven years time
and the seller's like wow my apartment
block is pretty run down needs a bit of
work he was he was not particularly he'd
lost interest in it so the seller was
like all right fine give it mean seven
years time but i want you to pay me rent
so you're gonna pay me rent for the i
think it was they agreed four thousand
pounds a month yeah four so he agreed my
friend pete to pay the seller four
thousand pounds a month
for an entire apartment block of 28
apartments with an option to buy at the
end of the seven years for six fifty
pete bought the apartment block and
spent twenty thousand pounds
which he didn't even use his own money
he used my friends tony's money he met
on my training board that's another
story so he then does the property up
like refurb he put the advert on spare
room code at uk i am not kidding kerry's
behind me is my witness how how many
people carrie will want him wanting to
rent those of those apartments in um in
sunderland
over 400 right so people just like
literally within a day bang bang bang
bang bang bang bang bang bang people
like i want it i want it i want i want
it so pete rents out the whole block
okay but then he gets a revaluation done
for 800 thousand so he's made a hundred
and fifty thousand pounds in forced
equity
he's he's renting the whole block out
for i think way over ten grand a month
so he's making income
so sunderland is interesting area very
cheap but number two
i thought this was number one but this
is number two number two the second
cheapest area in the country is bradford
bd1
interesting that a lot of the cheapest
areas are in the center maybe it's
because the centers aren't very good
maybe they're a bit crap maybe they run
down b you could buy a house in bradford
for 58 000 pounds
673 that's not even how much you can buy
a house for
that is the average house price
58 grand
average house in bd1 again there's no
article four you can then rent them out
room by room obviously before you do
this check the supply check the demands
but that takes me now to number one
the cheapest
area to buy a property in the uk
right now is
middlesbrough
now i've got a lot of houses in
middlesbrough i've bought a lot of
houses in middlesbrough you may have
seen on my youtube before the average
house in ts1 middlesbrough right now is
54
000 pounds
978 now this is the interesting thing
about middlesbrough you can buy a house
for 54 grand that's an average house in
ts1
but the rent on average
is 602 pounds
that means that your
your yield is 13.3
your return on investment if you were to
get a mortgage
can be 20 or higher
which means that your investment is paid
back within five years
middlesbrough so cheap anyway i'm gonna
go to middlesbrough now buy some more
houses i wanna know which area do you
think is the best not just the cheapest
the cheapest middlesbrough in the
country but where would you invest if
you were gonna invest in one of those
ten areas what did you make of the video
comment below i read every comment don't
forget to subscribe i'll see you next
time
[Music]